won multiple Emmy Awards for her work in
Glee love everything that she does not
just because I was on Hollywood game
night that she hosts but truly one of
the funniest people around and she's in
Ralph breaks the internet with john c
reilly Sarah Silverman Jack McBrayer gal
gadot taraji P Henson Alfred Molina and
more and O'Neil who I love that's that's
coming up in theaters near you on a
couple Wednesday
good to see you Jane good to see you
what if my name were rich I'd be rich
Lynch he would be well well I would my
name wouldn't be rich
well well in terms of ii-i'll go here
I'll go here to start this thing Jane
yeah you know in terms of rich there's
many different variations like Richard
yes Ricky there's yeah yeah you know so
you could probably fool around in there
yes well I mean I made a decision
years ago when I made my resume yes
professional name my professional name
yeah okay and I just thought to myself
being a sportscaster literally had this
decision from labeling my tapes do I go
you know there's no sportscaster Richard
you know what I'm saying there are there
are a lot of dick yeah you don't want to
go there that first of all it's in the
past and we can't say it now without
laughing dick Eisen you know in 1968
maybe right but not in 2018 no no I know
so I was a seer this decision was made
in the midst of mid mid 90s oh my god
you oppression yeah you know what I saw
down the road dick Eisen he didn't work
yeah at all so on it's so badly to
change my name into what well I don't
know my mom's maiden name was Carney and
I thought wouldn't Jane Carney be a
really nice name I was hoping praying
when I joined sag that there was a Jane
Lynch and I had to change it but not at
all I like it now I think it's nice it's
kind of it's a one-two punch it's worked
for you yeah it has it's definitely
worked for you are you from Chicago
I am yeah I grew up on the south side in
a suburb okay yeah
so are you a fan of any particular
Chicago sports team oh yes you know I
grew up on the south side so I should be
a Sox fan white
but I love the Cubs and the reason I
love the Cubs is kind of superficial is
because when I was growing up the White
Sox were on black and white on WFLD TV
UHF and the Cubs were on in living color
on channel 9 WGN so I think the Cubs
better and you know in my neighborhood
you did not wear your Cubs hat outside
could you get your butt kicked exactly
so you're a South Sider who likes the
gods because just because they were in
living color local exactly and then I of
course grew to love the you know the the
boys of summer as Harry Caray used to
call them and I would watch baseball
games while at work you know we always
had a little TV somewhere where were you
working I work temp jobs mostly and you
know I'd have under the old transistor
radio and I'd be listening to the
listening to the game and if there was a
television in the office we'd have it
turned on did you ever meet Harry do you
ever get no I didn't I didn't when I
went I went to Northwestern graduate
school I did that's after which is where
this big Richard rich dick thing went
down right so I went to Northwestern
Medill School of Journalism to you know
to so the reason why I bring that up is
I was at at school when the Cubs made a
managerial change and they had a press
conference at 10:00 in the morning so I
used my Medill School of Journalism
press card to go cover it and Harry
Caray was there at 10:00 in the morning
several Bloody Mary's into the day and
it's something I will never ever forget
that just seeing him there literally on
and just he definitely was not a sober
man no no no and he was a spokesperson
for for beer what was it the the Cubs
what was the beer for the straw he was
you know he was the color guy for those
socks that's right but when I was
growing up right and it was Falstaff
Falstaff right exactly all staff is
perfect you think he got the
Shakespearean oh god no I love listening
Damon before that was Jack Brickhouse
remember Jack horse did you grow up I
grew up in New York City okay but you
know
I'm an aficionado of Broadcasters in
broadcast so did you have any special
sort of emotional moment with the Cubs
finally winning it I did but you know it
was kind of removed because since I
lived in Los Angeles I am no longer a
big sports fan sure and I was big-time
when I was a kid right and so I was a
with a little bit of guilt at my
fair-weather fandom that I experienced
great joy I mean come on
I mean joy watching that watching that
series is fair fair weather phantom
doesn't matter when the Cubs break the
curse for over a hundred freaking years
yeah there's still quite good just but
you must have known people even on the
south side of Chicago for whom Cubs
World Series victory oh yeah never have
been imagined well all of my friends now
from high school were way into it way
into it the whole thing with the socks
and the Cubs you know as you get older
doesn't matter so much as sure and the
Sox won
what about 15 years ago they did yeah
they did they got their first which I'm
sure was a big deal yeah big deal
obviously but also that they could stick
it to their cubs friends Jane Lynch here
on the Rich Eisen show so Ralph breaks
the internet you are voicing the
characters sergeant tomorrow Jean
Calhoun are you a videogame aficionado
really no but I play a character in a
video game and I think it's based on
that really violent army game one just
named every video game so that was a lot
of fun the first movie actually voicing
that game you know it was really fun
okay and then have you have you seen the
finished product yet oh yeah oh I saw
the movie wreck-it Ralph
or what's it called the Ralph breaks the
internet run it's a gem it's really a
gem it is so sweet and so fun it's Ralph
and vanellope bob john c reilly and
Sarah Silverman going into the Internet
it is so amazingly magical and joyous
and and I mean of the imagination on
these guys rich more and Phil Johnston
who are the directors and the writers of
this and we also hear their voices a
couple of times some of the characters
it's just amazing they are off the
charts it's it's one of the most
delightful hour and a half's I've ever
spent well my kids are ten seven and
five all three of them know it's coming
they're aware it's on their radar screen
you mean you know it's making feel it if
it's Disney you can't avoid it yeah so
you know they love it
you know adults love it as well there's
a lot for the adult yeah I could see
that they're from the proof from the
previews that there are there's some
nuggets first oh absolutely
throughout the whole whole movie
absolutely all right Jane Lynch here on
the Rich Eisen show I'd love to play
celebrity true or false
here we go with Jane Lynch on the Rich
Eisen show crit hit it Mike del - faux
hit it first up with Jane Lynch
celebrity true or false true or false
your first on-screen credit was in the
judge reinhold Fred Savage classic vice
versa in 1988 I would say that's true
you were played Miz Lindstrom yes indeed
yes how did you get hooked up with this
Judge Reinhold Fred Savage well I was
living in Chicago and they shot it in
Chicago Fred Savage actually it was a
kid living in Chicago and it was a part
that they were local I was a local hire
as they call it
so I read I did a pre read with the
casting person and then you'd I read for
the director and the writers and they
were all British and it was a huge deal
it was I got into a major motion picture
and then so how much further along were
you with the being a Chicago resident in
the Chicago classic the fugitive that
came next
that was net that was another movie that
came through probably four years later
four years Leigh and then I was a local
hire for that one as well yeah that is
the most in my mind rewatchable movie
that is fugitive it does it hold up or
what it does that train wreck the train
wreck at the top for sure
it's a remote drop for me all the time
does not matter where it is yeah but you
know and I'm we are such huge fans of
the film huge we wanted you know on
behalf of the fans of the film thank you
for catching the switching of the
samples oh the liver samples you are
welcome rdu-90 you know wow you found
you know that I'm so glad you remember
that detail because that's I would say
to people that you don't remember from
it
I'm the one who did the liver sample I
solve the mystery you did delivers you
and bones you know once of course God
you remember everything telling you I've
seen this movie a million times and
wasn't the relationship between Harrison
Ford and Tommy Lee Jones quite wonderful
amazing yeah I love it
Tommy Lee Jones character obviously they
did another movie out of it but yeah
Harrison Ford perhaps the most beat up a
movie star of all time yeah oh yeah well
he does his own stunts too I mean that's
his own damn fault did you do your own
stunts I did all my own stunts I del I
actually handled the liver samples with
these fingers is unclothed see that's
not you know that's why you're as
successful as you are Jane you don't
leave any stone unturned thank you so
much yeah I go the extra mile it was in
the fugitive I'm so glad we got to catch
up on that next one for for Jane Lynch
your character and 40 year old virgin
Paula was originally written as a male
cat indeed you know I have a bit of a
history playing characters that were
originally written for men going all the
way back to like high school I played
the King in a short version of The
Princess and the pea yes indeed it was
written for a man and then with my
eternal gratitude Steve Carrell wife
Nancy walls who's a wonderful actress
actress herself said you know cuz I knew
them from Chicago said you know you have
a lot of men in your film wanted to read
Jane for the store manager and so we
improvised together and we had a lot of
fun and Judd Apatow said oh well we'll
cast her so I am very grateful to to
that whole crew of people for giving me
that job do you remember the song you
sang in yes I do in Spanish can you
oh absolutely I'll just tell you right
away that this is from an Al M Spanish
dialogue or D algo as you call it
and and and it's it's a dialogue and it
goes like this
mm-hmm quando Reglan me cuarto no and
quaint wrong mother don't be back on top
Lisa partido de futbol thank you
it means whenever I clean my room I
can't find anything where are you going
with such haste to a football game it's
not romantic at all no but the way it
sounds it's the way you deliver it you
nailed it you were cast in best-in-show
after Christopher guest's directed you
in a commercial for frosted flakes
indeed what I was doing a bunch of
commercials in like 1998-99 and I went
to a callback for a frosted flakes
commercial and they had the name of the
director up there at the callback and I
went because best I mean a waiting for
Guffman was like a transcendent
experience for me watching that movie
going I have to do this but it was a
preposterous fantasy so anyway I got
into the audition and he cast me and I
was just for bested for frost okay so
we're doing and it was basically
improvised type of a thing and
improvising about cereal yeah we were
yeah we were you know tony the tiger we
were stalking tony the tiger we were
great fans of tony the tiger and I don't
mean to correct you you were sorry sound
guy and no very good very good
and yeah so that was all improvising
then at lunch that day he said you know
I I do movies and I was like yeah and he
said maybe we'll get to work again
together and indeed we did within like
three or four months he was casting Best
in Show I ran into him at a restaurant
and he said I forgot about you come to
my office today and he offered me a part
and you're so fantastic in that oh thank
you you know you're a dog lover by the
way this is not part of celebrity true
or false but we we share the same of
veterinarian dr. Pratt your manager
Mahaney yes he's best in the business he
is the best in show yeah he is best
show for sure nice guy and you and
that's such a funny movie next one in
2010 you were nominated for a Golden
Globe for Best Performance by an actress
in a supporting role for Glee but you
slept through the nomination and I did I
didn't realize that I'd get it nominated
for an award I didn't know that that was
gonna happen and then my agent called me
and she left me all these messages going
why are Joey
why aren't you you were nominated you
were nominated so I'd like four or five
different voicemail messages for from
her and it happens early it happens like
5:00 in the morning right so but you
turn your phone off overnight I didn't
hear it I guess you know I'm definitely
near we've been through this we have and
I put the good ear down to go to sleep I
don't hear a damn thing right guys I
just called you Rick Frosted Flakes
sweatshirt I owned that that was my
mother that was my mother's sweatshirt
it was it was a button-down sweatshirt
that had a little kitty cat caught in
some yarn it was adorable I had watched
the commercial that belonged to my
mother made so you brought your own
sweatshirt yeah I said what do you think
of this he said it's perfect no wonder
Christopher guest's did you know my own
wardrobe Chris man he cast me over and
over again because I bring my own
wardrobe and then you won in the same
category for Sue Sylvester the next year
thank you and then the rest is history
yeah total that was did you base that
character on anybody uh yes you know
subconsciously I've kind of realized who
I was doing that I had a teacher in
college her name was dr. Jean Scharffen
Berger and everybody was scared to death
of her and she would literally walk
through the halls in the students would
split like the Red Sea you know
everybody was afraid of her you wanted
to have her attention because she was
such a great teacher but you also kind
of hid from her because she could be
really shaming and and mean but deep
down inside she was so tender-hearted so
and I was able to see that about her I
was scared at first and then I saw oh
this this woman is hiding some great
vulnerabilities and I saw her be
vulnerable you know a couple of times
and I thought what a sweetheart and you
know you don't have to try so hard you
know so I think that's where I got sue
because sue deep down inside
was a real soft person but she was mean
as hell on the outside well thanks for
coming on the show here Jane this has
been a fun chat
it has been fun chat down memory lane
and so check out Ralph breaks the
internet in theaters near you next
Wednesday November 21st Hollywood game
night returns next year on NBC and once
again thank you for your hard work
without which Devlin MacGregor could
perhaps be in business still today made
Akhter nickels doing his nefarious teas
you know and dr. Kimble would be in jail
still oh I know jail if it weren't for
me and I forget my character's name if
it wasn't Kathy why go it comes back to
you it does but unlike the Spanish song
from 40 year old virgin it's always
right there that's always right so thank
that Jane Marie Lynch on Twitter that
was a lot of fun thank you for coming
out you bet again Ralph breaks the
Internet and theaters near you right in
time for Thanksgiving weekend the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience